hello everyone here we have a wonderful
game played by Grandmaster Simon
Williams who I believe needs no
introduction one of the greatest chess
commentators in the world like I said a
grandmaster and also he names all of his
pawns
so definitely quite a guy this was
played in the last round of the Northern
Lights Open tournament in Reykjavik I
was held from 10th at the 15th of
November and he's playing against the
Lithuanian Grandmaster cranissaa loses
Simon finished the tournament in third
place with six points out of nine and
the mr. Lewis is finished with five and
a half points in fifth place so if
someone lost this game Alice's would
probably win first place in this
tournament so definitely a strong player
so let's see this game Simon has the
white pieces and he plays d4 Knight to
f6 c4 e6 Knight to f3 d5 the Queens
gambit declined Knight to c3 now see 5c
chapters on d5 the semi taro Knight
captures on d5 and III Knight to c6
Bishop to d3 developing Bishop to e7
Simon castles we have castles a3 now see
capture son d4e capture son d4 and
Bishop to f6 putting pressure on the d4
pawn bishops to c2 now the Queen is
defending the pawn and Knight see to e7
and here we have h4 by Simon Williams
Harry the h-bond begins his journey and
probably here for black a move like
Knight to f5 or maybe b6 preparing
Bishop to b7 would be better but mr.
Lewis knows he's playing against Simon
Williams and he's afraid of Harry BH
bond and he defends over to g6 not
really stopping h5 but okay making room
for making room for the bishop and g7
rook to e1 Bishop to d7 preparing to
develop the Bishop and c6 Knight to e4
Bishop to g7
now we have h5 Bishop to c68 captures
and g 6h captures and g6 and night F to
g5 and it doesn't matter what the
evaluation evaluation of this
is if it's an equal position or if black
is better white has these bishops eyeing
the black King both of the Knights are
in the attack the king is ready to jump
into the attack so definitely a more
comfortable position for White Knight to
f6 now ix captures on f6 Bishop captures
on f6 and Queen to g4 with ideas of
Queen to h4 and queen to h7 checkmate
so King to g7 now Queen to h4 will be
met with rook to h8 of course Bishop to
f4 here Simon offers the d4 pawn and is
this justified well black is defending
so I guess anything is justified Queen
captures on d4 and now Simon's main idea
comes into play rook captures on e6
what's the idea
well you can't capture the rook if you
capture it Knight captures an e6 for
King the king and the Queen you lose the
Queen and the game try to recapture sin
e6 Queen capture some be to getting the
Queen out of harm's way
and why not this is a perfect fine move
rook 831 as the rock on a1 was a tech
now Simon doubles up on the e-file
Bishop to d7 now pinning the rook if you
move the rook you lose the Queen so what
do you play here Simon plays Queen to h3
now threatening Queen to h7 checkmate
and this is definitely the most critical
moment in the game
his opponent played rook to h8 to stop
this idea but if he had played Bishop
captures on g5 removing the defender of
the h7 Square this is actually perfectly
fine for black and black black would
have a nice game for example Bishop to
e5 would check yes this does win the
Queen but the Queen simply captures the
bishop you can capture with the e6 rook
because you lose the Queen the bishop is
attacking the Queen so after rook 1
captures on e5 simply Bishop captures
rook and now what do you do if you play
something like rook captures F captors
and Queen captures rook the c8 and black
is fine
he has sufficient material to counter
the Queen and the bishop and a good game
for black
would be so after this Queen to h3 moved
he didn't go for Bishop characters and
g5 his opponent played rock to h8 and
here we have rook captures on f6 another
brilliant move by Simon Williams giving
black a lot of options do capture the
Queen with the rook to capture the Queen
with the bishop do you capture the rook
on f6 with the Queen so let's just check
a couple of moves if you play rook
captures for example rook captures on h3
then you allow route captors on f7 would
check and if you play something like
into g8g captures on h3 and the problem
is you can't capture the bishop on c2 if
you capture at Queen captures on c2 you
get rook eek after Sonny 7 and the black
cannot stop checkmate okay he can but he
has to give up the Queen if you please
a silly move like Bishop to a5 to save
the bishop you're instantly getting
checkmated ruby g7 checking HH rook age
7 sure King g8 now rook g7 check King f8
and Bishop to d6 check King it and rocky
g8 this is checkmate and if you don't if
you play after rook captures and he
seven something like Queen d1 checked no
problem king h2 and you're simply out of
checks Queen d4 has to be played and now
you lose the Queen and the game so after
rook captures and f6 rook captures and
h3 doesn't really seem like a plan so
let's check wing captors on f6 if you
play this you get Queen captures on d7
now you're up two pieces for a rook so
if Queen captures f4 simply Queen
captures on e7 and a much much better
position for white you have two pieces
for the rook and unfortunately for black
Queen h2 check doesn't work King f1 now
Queen to h1 check King e - and it seems
like rook to e8 accomplishes something
but not really 936 with check you can't
go to the H file with the King because
the Rock each one comes with tempo so
after something like King to g8 you
capture the rook with Czech rep captures
and now rock out the screen on h1 and
after you recapture the night you have a
rook and the bishop against the rook
okay you're down upon that doesn't
really matter and easily winning endgame
for white so lastly after rook captures
and f6 we get to the move that was
played in the game Bishop captures on h3
seven plays rook captures on f7 King g8
and now G captures on h3 you still can't
capture the bishop even in this line
because of the the same idea rook
captures night on e7 so here black is
already defending for quite a quite a
while and it's not always easy to find
the best defending move when you're
defending so he played Knight to c6 a
somewhat better move would have been a
Knight to d5 this comes through the
temple and the bishop on f4 and it stops
Bishop to e4 but okay he played Knight
to c6 and now we have Bishop to e4 and
preparing Bishop to d5 and after rook to
the rook to e8 rook to d7 now Bishop to
Bishop to d5 will come with tempo rook
to e7 now Bishop to d5 with the check
came to a fate and now you pin the rook
and black is pretty much out of options
here he did try one more thing as he is
a grandmaster Queen to f6 and okay this
does have some poison to it if you
capture the rook now with Bishop
captures on e7 Knight captures and after
nine three six check for example King
goes to e8 Rudy 8 check King f7 the
problem is you don't have a good
discovery with the night not really
so this would give black some chances as
the White King is somewhat open as well
but after Queen to f6
Simon finds the the absolute best move
he plays Knight to e4 now attacking the
Queen the Queen has to move Queen to h4
was played and Bishop captures and c6 so
it was a it was a very stormy game so
after the storm has had calmed down and
now a simple quiet move better captures
and c6 removing the defender of the rook
on e7 this is perfectly fine and the
winning for Simon if you play something
like rook to h7
sorry this was played route 7 and salmon
played night 2 G 3 now opening up the
attack from drew Connie wanted arou
Connie 7 and in this position the
Athenian Grandmaster resigned the game
there's really nothing for you to do
here if you capture the bishop would be
capturing on c6 you don't even have to
react to the rope that is pinned you can
simply capture a poem like has nothing
to do here and after black plays a
threatening move for example Queen to f6
the threat and the bishop now you
capture and after captures captures
Europe you have two rooks and the night
for a queen a completely winning game
for white black life has nothing here he
will either have to give up the Queen or
he is getting checkmated so yeah that's
the game from the Northern Lights open
tournament in Reykjavik last round round
9 played by Simon Williams a wonderful
game and I really enjoyed the quote I
saw on Twitter from chess calm you can
see it up there above the board hope you
liked it as usual you can check to my
previous videos here I would like to
thank Henrik for Stephen major Lee mija
boo he'll and Robson Pelerin
communications incorporated for a
contribution to my channel I think a lot
I really appreciate it thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon